[Music]
you've been a Victoria's Secret Angel
since 2009 I remember because I'm a
student at Victoria's Secret when they
first came out with the Angels I
remember yeah yeah I'm always I've never
allowed into the shows I'm just that
creep in the background but the the the
women wear these started out wearing
these very conventional sort of
beautiful wings and then it feels like
it's morphed over time into these sort
of things that suggest wings but also
suggest all other kinds of things that
look but look at that that looks
impossible to walk with that was like 25
pounds that was very heavy yeah and it's
not even a wing anymore it's like the
inside of a diesel engine that you're
walking around it we have another one
and I don't know that's just mashed
potatoes that's your salute to carbs I
love that no but are you nervous like
it's it's must be nerve-racking enough
to walk down a runway in the crazy heels
with all these people looking without
that then they strap a 25-pound device
to you do you have a fear when you're
walking in the runway and you're wearing
that my one fear I mean falling is the
worst thing but my one fear is falling
and in such heavy wings because can you
imagine you fall and then you cannot get
up right you're just lying on the floor
with wings like you can never know like
a turtle yeah you're like a turtle and
you're just there yeah and you know the
other girls are just gonna you know the
show must go on they're just gonna walk
right they're gonna step over you
because what am I gonna do yeah I'm sure
they'd be some gentleman that would rush
up and help you I
you